It's amazing what you can get off the free
section of your local classified adds.
Now for some reason, people throw
expensive things away all the time, just because they won't turn
on. But with a little ambition, some peoples
junk can be a goldmine of opportunity.
Let's open this thing up and see what we can
find inside. To get started let's push a putty
knife gently under the fasteners so we can
pry them up slowly and release the catches.
When enough of them are removed, the pegboard
backing pulls away, to reveal a wondrous playground
of awesome electrical components. Not to mention
a butter knife and a whole lot of dusty cobwebs.
These powerful 12" speakers should be awesome,
for experiments with non-newtonian fluids,
and they're probably worth around $50 each.
The foot pedal at the bottom controls 2 potentiometers,
that could be repurposed for loads of electrical
projects as well. Right here we've got a rocker
switch with insulated spade connectors, and
this just the beginning. Now I took a minute
to explore how these organ keys actually play
music, and it's mind blowing how simple the
mechanics really are. Now if we remove the
top panel from the organ, we can access the
power controller, and salvage some of the
protective fuses, but check this out. The
mains power fuse, isn't conducting any electricity.
That means its probably been fried. So what
would happen if we tried bypassing the fuse
with a jumper cable? You can see now, that
when we flip the switch, the organ fires right
up, and is working just fine. It's just that easy.
Now I have a similar fuse from a previous
project, that we can use to replace the broken
one, and now that the circuits are protected
again, let's replace all the paneling, and
snap the pegboard back into place. What was
once a broken piece of junk, is now back to
proper working condition, and it's purpose
has instantly been restored. I tested out
the keys and the foot pedals, then decided
to go ahead and shine the whole thing up to
look a bit nicer. When my kids figured out
we had a new noisemaker in the house, they
went crazy for it, and spent a couple of weeks,
playing with the power at their fingertips.
Now at first I thought we could sell this
and make a couple hundred dollars. But then
my wife and I had a different idea. We drove
down to a local charity, wrapped the organ
in ribbons, and gave it away with a big red
bow, hoping that some family out there, would
enjoy it a little more than we did. So you
see in the end, we didn't make any money on
this deal, and I didn't get any new parts
for future projects either. But I can say
this. That now I've donated one of my organs,
to charity. Well that's it for now. If you
liked this project, perhaps you'll like some
of my others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com